not so many years ago housecleaning was a
time-consuming back-breaking job for the
housewife when she disliked heartily
if she had one of the early cleaners
she was considered lucky cleaning was
a step up the back and she still had
to assemble buckets ladders mops
and sweepers to really do the job
but today the modern vacuum cleaner has taken all
that drudgery out of cleaning and it's ready to
go to work for you at a moment's notice see how
easily it goes over the door still out onto the
floor up onto the rug without once catching or
tipping it swivels easily - all because of the
big rubber tyred wheels there's no lifting
dragging or carrying the light ones easily
lock in place and there's even a specially
designed grip to keep the arm and wrist from
getting tired and yet with all of these advantages
many women still don't get the most out of their
vacuum cleaner a lot of research has been done by
manufacturers to find the best method of cleaning
questionnaires and time and motion studies
have shown that if you follow certain general
rules you'll do your cleaning easier and faster
above the floor cleaning should be done first
the draperies are a good place to start
you begin by setting the power dial which
has settings for floors rugs and
general ceilings cotton carpeting
or in this case where you cut down the suction
for drapery all the cleaning tools you need for
each cleaning job right right along with
the cleaner in the compact built into Iraq
for draperies and upholstery use the upholstery
tool the floating brush loosens any clinging dirt
using one or both ones gives you the reach you
need to clean all the way to the top with the
upholstery nozzles flat against the drapery such
and brush all the dust that makes the colors
appear dull and faded and be sure your strokes
overlap each other so the drapery is thoroughly
cleaned when that's done the upholstered
furniture is easily cleaned with the same tool
when you suction clean upholstered furniture
this way you actually get all the dust off
the fabric before it gets a chance to work in and
dull the colors they'll stay brighter much longer
with the surface cleaned the crevice tool
will reach a lot of hard to get at places for
example between the cushions and sides the posted
furniture see how it pays to use the crevice tool
now here is the new and quick way to do
all your dusting suction dusting with a
sickly bristle brush allows you to reach a
lot of home furnishings that you couldn't do
with an old-fashioned uh scattering cloth it's
wonderful for lampshades both outside and inside